vous avez bâti un empire de toutes
pièces ces métastases et je n'en ai pas
pour petit mois aux yeux du monde
vos immeubles vous rendre aux immortels
où voulez-vous mur vous sentez-vous est
mortelle nous offrons aux plus grands de
nos esprits plus de temps pour
s'accomplir pleinement
des j'arrive en une coquille vide c'est
une chanson c'est un aller simple
qu'est ce que c'est ça permet d'arrêter
votre coeur quoi je suis né le 20
septembre 1980
m'appelle eduard kiener tâchez de vous
reposer un peu amusez vous après tout à
votre âge vous l'avez bien mérité
ce n'était pas une hallucination
la mort à certains effets secondaires et
qu'elle garde cette femme croit que son
mari mort
j'ai exercé votre souhait
mais voulu que d'autres au square
sans moi votre esprit rechutera
les plus dangereux récompensé
avec damian tous les progrès de la
médecine en temps
à